ils se sont tour à tour admirés détestés
réconciliés et après le 2 conflit
mondial Winston Churchill et Charles de
Gaulle ont donc chacun écrit et publié
leur mémoire de guerre c'est ce duel
d'écrivain de mémorialiste à fleur et
moucheté auquel s'est donc intéressé de
près ce documentaire exclusif que nous
venons de voir son réalisateur Pierre
Assouline est maintenant avec nous sur
ce plateau en compagnie de nos autres
invités Pierre Assouline bienvenue merci
c'est donc à vous que nous devons ce
film vous êtes réalisateur de
documentairees journaliste chroniqueur
radio biographe romancier membre entre
autres du comité de rédaction du
magazine l'histoire que nous saluons
d'ailleurs au passage cette rédaction de
l'histoire et aussi membre de l'Académie
concours et votre dernier livre
s'intitule le nageur publié chez galimar
il retrace le destin du nageur Alfred
nakchee sélectionné au JO de Berlin en
36 mais aussi euh à ceux de Londres en
48 mais entre les deux son histoire
s'avère réellement hors du commun et
c'est cette histoire qui est à découvrir
sous votre plume aux éditions galimar
bienvenue François kersudi vous êtes
historien spécialiste de l'œuvre de De
Gaulle et de Churchill dont vous avez
traduit et retraduit plus exactement en
français les mémoires de guerre de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale très exactement
celle dont il est question euh dans ce
film que nous venons de voir vous avez
consacré une biographie euh à church
Chile mais aussi à de Gaulle et vous
avez par ailleurs consacré un livre aux
relations entre les deux hommes d'abord
écrit en anglais puis en français et
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule 10
faces caché du communisme et c'est un
ouvrage à découvrir aux éditions Perin
enfin Jean-Luc Barret est avec nous
bienvenue Jean-Luc Barret très heureux
de vous recevoir vous êtes écrivain
historien et éditeur directeur des
éditions boucin vous être l'auteur entre
autres de devenir de GO l'ouvrage publié
aux éditions Périn et plus récemment de
l'homme de personne
1890-
1944 premier volume d'un tripticque
biographique intitulé de Gaul une vie
publiée chez grassay et qui vous a
d'ailleurs valu le Prix renaudo essay
les sorties des deux autres volumes sont
prévu en 2025 et en
2027 pierreassouline on a peut-être
besoin de comprendre ce qui était votre
intention le Paris était risqué avec ce
regard croisé entre les mémoires de
guerre de ces deux hommes à propos du
du second conflit mondial quelle était
votre intention sur le je suis parti
d'abord de l'admiration que je porte
pour les deux sur les deux hommes autant
Churchill que de Gaulle chacun pour des
raisons différentes mais c'est une
admiration historique ensuite je suis
parti également ça se superpose d'une
admiration littéraire et d'un point de
vue d'écrivain parce que le point de vue
des historiens a été développé très
souvent y compris à la télévision mais
moins on les a moins aperçu sur ce
plan-là ou en tout en tout cas envisager
ou analyser et même comparer sur ce
plan-l et donc je trouvais intéressant
de de comparer d'abord première chose
comment est-ce qu'il pouvait raconter
les mêmes événements mais chacun à sa
manière donc voir les deux phases d'un
même événement ça étant évident que
c'est c'est entre 40 et 45 à partir des
mémoires de guerre exclusivement et
ensuite comparer les mérites littéraires
des deux je dois vous avouer mais ça ça
se perçoit dans le commentaire que mon
admiration littéraire admiration
d'écrivain va évidemment à de Gaulle qui
pour moi est un grand styliste et moins
à le plus shakespearien des deux n'est
pas celui qu'on pense celon croitê vous
êtes davantage convaincu par le de GO
l'écrivain que Church l'écrivain
absolument et ce qui m'avit toujours
surpris je dirais pas choqué parce qu'il
faut pas exagérer c'est qu'il ait pu
avoir le le le prix Nobel de littérature
Marquet lui-même a été surpris de la
voir il voulait le prix Nobel de la paix
mais ce qui m'a surpris c'est que
finalement quand on voit les attendus du
comité Nobel on comprend que ils lui ont
ils l'ont décerné alors peut-être pour
des raisons diplomatique nous sommes
quand même pas très loin de
l'après-gerre ou euh mais 1953 1953 mais
décerné avant tout à l'historien et à
l'homme des discours finalement on se
demande si les chef-dœuvres de Churchill
se sont pas ces discours et puis quand
même dès qu'on creuse on s'aperçoit bien
entendu que il y avait derrière
Churchill à nombre de gens oui qui ont
travaillé qu'on découvre dans votre film
pour ceux qui ne savaient pas si
sont au service de de Churchill c'est ce
que vous dites dans ce film qu'ppelle
son synd il y a des
Daco c'est c'est un homme qui parle
c'est un hom vous appz le consortium
Churchill finalement dans ce film
syndicaï comme il dit comme il disait
mais c'est un comment dire c'est un
homme du verbe et c'est un un formidable
orateur donc c'est un homme qui parle et
qui raconte et à ça il est impeccable
mais pour moi le le styliste sur le plan
littéraire c'est c'est bien sûr de
Gaulle
intéressant de de comparer les deux on
va voir ce qu'on pense François kersi
c'est vrai que euh souvent on dit
qu'avec Kipling show Wells bien Winston
Churchill est l'un des quatre plus
grands écrivains britanniques du du 20e
siècle c'est pas tout à fait rien est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce regard
croisé porté par Pierre Assouline et
puis cette conclusion de de finalement
préférer l'écrivain de Gaul à l'écrivain
Churchill alors il faut voir plusieurs
Chav de leur mémoire de Guer ch d'abord
ils ont pas ils ont pas voulu écrire la
même chose non plus ils ont voulu faire
chacun une œuvre c'est certain mais rien
qu'avec le titre vous voyez que
l'ambition n'était pas la même de Gaulle
hein c'était mémoire de guerre
c'està-dire la France et moi moi au
service de la France turchill c'est pas
ça hein de Second World War hein la
Seconde Guerre mondiale il il il a pour
ambition d'écrire toute l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale donc forcément
il va pas faire la même chose bien
entendu de temps en temps assez souvent
d' il intervient mais vous avez des
quantités des épisode de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale dans lequel il
intervient pas du tout hein la guerre du
Pacifique la guerre en Russie en Union
soviétique il a rien à voir là dedans
mais il raconte etid comme il peut pas
tout raconter et bien il a recruté des
gens pour raconter à sa place et puis
après il chur chilise hein mais c'est
c'est pas la même c'est pas la même
ambition au
départ en ce qui concerne euh alors les
beaucoup de gens m'ont dire ah c'est
curieux qu'il a reçu le prix Nobel et
cetera et à chaque fois je dis mais vous
l'avez lu en anglais ou en français ils
m'ont dit bon français naturellement ah
oui mais alors la traduction de l'époque
il faut voir comment était la traduction
de l'époque grâce à vous aujourd'hui on
peut le lire en français et moi je l'ai
lu en partie en anglais et dans votre
version à vous ce n'est pas si différent
que ça ah si parce que la traduction
originaleis il y a de très belles
phrases c'est beau
rythmé
le lecteur de ces lignes doit compr et
vous imitez parfaitement bien Winston
Churchill hein pour ceux qui n'auraient
pas compris ou mais le lecteur de CG
doit comprendre combien est opaque et
déroutant le voile de l'inconnu c'est
beau quand
même autrement dit convaincu par ce qui
était le style littéraire de Churchill
plus que celui de De Gaulle non non non
non non non chacun est un maître dans
son domaine si on si c'est pour dire de
GA aurait mérité le prix c'est tout à
fait évident mais ils étaient pas en
compétition ils pouvaient pas le l'ettre
en ce qui concerne le prix Nobel ça lui
a été attribué on a effectivement fait
très attention de ne pas parler de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale parce qu'on
savait effectivement comment ça avait
été rédigé mais ça lui a été attribué
d'ailleurs comme toujours le prix Nobel
pour l'ensemble de l'œuvre et l'ensemble
de l'œuvre c'est quoi 27 autres livres
400 articles
2583 10 discours et la différence est
d'autant moins marquée qu'il avait
l'habitude de dicter ses livres et
d'écrire ses discours hein donc pour lui
il y avait effectivement pas pas
vraiment de différence vous l'avez dit
he pierre assouine n'a pas pris soin
d'aller recevoir ce prix Nobel de de la
littérature en 53 à Stockholm parce que
lui il espérait le prix Nobel de était
déçu de l'APP Jean-Luc Barret euh je
dirais que sur pour de Gaulle il y a il
y a l'idée d'un témoigner de laisser un
témoignage historique mais c'est quand
même une œuvre d'écrivain qu'il veut
faire parce que c'est je pense qu'il y a
chez De Gaulle peut-être un écrivain
beaucoup plus encore que chez chez
chield d'abord il a écrit très jeune des
textes il a publié toute une série de
livres avec un soin particulier au style
je ve dire donc c'est un écrivain
solitaire un homme qui travaill
énormment j'ai travaillé sur les les
manuscrits de ses mémoires et j'ai vu à
quel point il travaillait comme un
écrivain véritablement avec beaucoup de
peine d'ailleurs texes r he parce que
vous avez retrouvé les originaux du côté
de la BNF he oui c'est très
impressionnant très
impressionant et donc on peut dire que
c'est pas seulement on peut pas non plus
se fier totalement je je l'ai vérifié à
travers la biographie que je viens de
rédiger au mémoir de guerre de De Gaulle
pour savoir la vérité exacte peut-être
c'est plus fiable parfois chez Churchill
qui veut pas dire qu'il y a pas un point
de vue des deux côtés mais voilà donc il
y a a y a a chez De Gaulle le souci
d'abord de laisser une œuvre littéraire
et de construire son mythe c'est
incontestablement les mémoires de guerre
sont là aussi pour construire le myth de
De Gaulle ceci étant c'est aussi un Témo
age superbe magnifique sur sur tout cela
des portraits extraordinaires le
portrait de Churchill le portrait
d'Hitler le portrait de Staline donc on
a affaire quand même à une grande œuvre
un grand témoignage du du niveau de des
grands témoignages historiques hein de
de de César ou de du cardinal de ou
parfois de Saint-Simon d'ailleurs alors
si j'ai bien compris la chronologie hein
Churchill a publié les six thôes de ses
Mémoires de guerre sur la Seconde Guerre
mondiale entre 48 et 53 et de Gaulle lui
entre 54 et 59 autrement dit De Gaulle
aurait pu jeter un œil et plus qu'un œil
sur les les mémoir écrit par Churchill à
l'époque puisqu'il sort les siennes
après cell de Churchill certainement
d'autant plus qu'il les avait à colomber
dans son bureau juste derrière lui on
les voit d'ailleurs là donc oui bien sûr
sa curiosité était aiguisée aussitôt
faut imaginer quand même que la parution
des mémoires de Churchill c'est un
succès considérable c'est un événement
mondial pas seulement en langue anglaise
mais dans le reste du monde oui et les
les gens comme le général d'ailleurs on
ont relut ont lu cette traduction eu
donc il ont pas ils sont pas intéressés
à à l'original une autre chose qui a
scandalisé de Gaulle c'est que
euh Churchill les livre de Churchill a
été publié d'abord aux États-Unis et
donc lui il disait mais vous imaginez de
Gaul être publié d'abord en Belgique au
Canada ce serait scandaleux et cetera et
et puis en plus
euh les bonnes feuilles ont été publiées
dans Time et dans l' avant publication
et là aussi il était scandalisé hein
est-ce que vous imaginez vauvenar ou
Saint-Simon se faire publier dans les
gazettes de Paris parce qu'il faut
jamais oublier s'agissant de churchy la
dimension financière c'estàd que ces
écrits en général mais depuis tout jeune
he c'est un complètement de revenu non
non non c'est le revenu c'est pas reven
son revenu toute sa vie de sa plume
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire dès dès
son plus jeune âge quand il était encore
à l'armée il envoyait des articles qui
étaient publiés dans la presse et là la
la la prépuation dans la il fait dans
Time bien sûr obéit à des considérations
financières évidentes donc ça ça ça
compte beaucoup hein ah bah oui il
n'avait que ça comme revenu parce que le
le les les parlementaires étaient
horriblement mal payés der au début il
était même pas du tout et et en plus il
avait un train de vie assez assez
somptueux donc rien que les mémoires de
guerre enfin les mémoir Second World War
ça lui a rapporté
550000 livres de l'époque ce qui fait 43
millions de dollars c'est important
d'ailleurs de dire aussi que pour de
Gaulle dans cette période làà de Gaulle
n'a les seuls revenus réels de De Gaulle
vont être ses mémoires pendant toute une
période de de de sa vie en tout cas
cette période là des années 50 puisquil
a refusé sa retraite il a il ne voulait
rien de voir à l'état c'est d'ailleurs
un mystère de savoir exactement de quoi
il a vécu dans cette période au-delà des
mémoires je pense que son frère qui
était banquier sans doute là ça fait par
des éléments que que j'essaierai de
clarifier dans le dans le qu'il a fait
une donation à la Fondation Charles de
Gaul oui la Fondation Anne de Gaul oui
oui bien sûr mais en fait il fallait
bien tout de même qu'il vive et et une
grande partie des mémoires lui ont
permis de vivre dans cette dans cette
période là puisqu'il avait des rapports
avec à l'argent très différents de ceux
de Churchill je pense pas que le train
de vie soit comparable mais et donc il
avait mais il fallait effectivement dans
la mesure son indépendance passer aussi
par par le fait de gagner de l'argent
avec ses mémoires juste un mot quand
même degal a porté un jugement sur les
mémoires de Churchill il y a une phrase
où il dit quel était-il ce jugement s'il
fallait le résumer il a dit c'est juste
un bout à bout c'est juste un bout juste
un bout à bout oui c'est ça il a mis
bout à bout beaucoup de choses oui oui
ce qui ce qui est vrai et faux à la fois
çap ça dépend des chapitres alors ça
nous amène sur les relations ce qu'on
été les relations entre les deux hommes
on les parcours pour un certain nombre
d'entre ell dans votre film Pierre
Assouline la première rencontre entre
les deux hommes c'est le 9 juin
1940 ils ne se connaissent pas Churchill
connaî Paul Renault il connaît Mondel
mais il conna endu parler tout de même
il a tout de même entendu parler de de
ce de il y a moncnet tout ça il a
entendu parler de ça mais ça reste très
lointain et de toute façon on sait très
bien que c'est pas lui qui l'attendait
spécialement à Londres donc c'est pour
lui mais il y a quand même cette
rencontre plutôt Mel he qui l'attendait
à oui en il attendait tout le monde il
attendait Mandel il attendait peut-être
daran il attendait peut-être Bloom il a
le seul qui qui qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur cette première rencontre et comment
en rendent-ils compte chacun de leur
côté parce que c'est souvent la bonne
impression hein la première impression
l'impression on la connaî de de de
cherschill puisqu'il a parlé très vite
de l'homme du destin donc il a il aurait
entrevu soi-disant l'homme du destin je
pense qu'il y a une part de myth
derilleurs tout ça quant à de Gaulle je
pense qu'il a il a tout de suite été
impressionné mais il l'avait vu il l'a
retrouvé ensuite à Londres avant même
d'ailleurs le 18 juin donc impressionné
par effectivement la ce qui manquait le
plus à la France à ce moment-là au
dirigeants français c'est la volonté de
se battre donc il y a quand même quelque
chose et puis chez De Gaulle il y a le
sens de du du personnage historique du
héros d'une certaine manière et
incontestablement voilà du connaable il
le reconnaî il reconnaît ce personnage
là aussi chez chez Churchill connaable
c'est le surnom qu'on on donnait à don à
voilà ou absolument donc il y a quand
même la rencontre là de de deux
personnages qui qui qui sont deux hommes
du destin d'une certaine manière et
c'est raconté à peu près de la même
manière je pense des deux des deux côtés
alors l'homme du destin ça ça aurait été
l'expression utilisée par par Churchill
pour qualifier de Gaal après leur
première rencontre peu de temps après en
tout cas c'est la légende ou pas la
légende pour répondre à ce que vient de
dire Jean-Luc Barret ça et Churchill
avait des intuitions fulgurantes c'est
pas la première hein il avait très
curieuse capacité à à voir dans l'avenir
et à voir les
possibilités par ailleurs c'était
aussi un propagandiste de génie et donc
l'homme du destin c'est parce qu'il
avait besoin d'un homme du destin et
pourquoi est-ce qu'il en avait besoin
c'est parce qu'il voyait bien que la
France allait s'effondré d'ailleurs la
France s'est effondré et il avait très
peur en fait que les les Anglais cèdent
pend la Première Guerre mondiale les
Français n'avaient pas cédé et et donc
les Anglais n'avaient pas été menacés
d'invasion là la France cède et d'un
seul coup il a peur que les politiciens
parce qu'il y en a disent bah voilà
notre rempart sur le continent à céd bah
écoutez on va négocier avec Hitler et et
donc Churchill qui a une imagination
fertile propagandiste de génie il
présente de Gou euh à son opinion
publique à ses députés en leur disant
vous croyez comme ça
que la France a capitulé mais non elle a
pas capitulé puisqu'elle continue la
lutte euh grâce à ce c'est cet homme
remarquable de Gaulle hein fine fighting
soldier with a good reputation and
strong personality alors en ce qui
concerne la strong personality
évidemment il aura l'occasion de
regretter un peu plus tard mais pour le
moment c'est l'homme qu' lui faut c'est
l'homme du destin c'est l'homme pour de
mon destin qui va me permettre de
d'encourager la la la population
euh les députés les ministres tous ces
gens qui sont assez rétissant quand même
hein à continuer le combat parce que la
France continue le combat à vos côtés
vous voyez c'est c'est l'imagination de
l'homme et ça fonctionne très bien je me
dis que en vous écoutant que tous les
deux que finalement Churchill était
avveit de très bonnes intuitions sur de
gale puisque les deux biographes de De
Gaulle ont repris des expressions chur
chilienne l'homme du destin
pour vous et le connaéable pour la
couture pour Jean la couture ce sont
deux expressions de churchilleld pour
qualifier de Gaulle c'est que quand même
il avait bien senti le personnage alors
que comme vous le dites personnage à
l'époque un inconnu ce sont d'ailleurs
c'est c'est curieux parce que finalement
durant toutes ces années 30 ils sont ils
sont pratiquement les seuls écarné une
forme de de résistance et de lucidité
par rapport à leur opinion leur
gouvernement vis-à-vis du danger du
danger qui est en face de de nous
c'estàd le danger nazi et cetera ils
sont ils sont assez solitaires
finalement ils se rencontrent aussi
parce qu'ils ont partagé à un moment
donné les mêmes les mêmes alarmes les
mêmes inquiétudes et les même combat oui
mais à l'époque deg n'est pas un homme
public non mais il écrit des livres il
dit des choses bien sûr non maisch
lui-même est dans une situation pas oui
bien sûr évidment bon il reste quand
même que Churchill a l'essentiel de sa
carrière politique derrière lui il a 60
ans
40 et donc 16 ans de plus que que de
Gaulle et de Gaulle lorsqu'il rencontre
pour la première fois church n'est que
sous-secrétaire d'État à la Guerre et à
la défense nationale autrement dit quand
de Gaulle arrive à à Londres c'est un
obligé c'est un obligé or être être un
obligé pour de GA c'était pas quelque
chose de très naturel du tout le
sentiment qu'il veut avoir d'ailleurs
mon livre s'appelle l'homme de personne
aussi c'est pas par hasard parce que
l'homme de personne c'est une formule
qu'il a employé en août 40 quand on lui
a demandé en quelque sorte de se
présenter parce que les Anglais
voulaient le faire connaître et au lieu
de dire voilà Charles de Gaulle né à né
à tel à tel moment et à telle date et je
bon il dit je suis l'homme de personne
c'est une façon de se présenter et c'est
c'est déjà une forme de défi euh
vis-à-vis des Anglais pas seulement
vis-à-vis des Anglais d'ailleurs m dit
je ne suis l'homme d'aucun parti d'aucun
politicien je n'appartiens qu'à la
France et à Dieu bon et donc c'est déjà
une manière de se de se singulariser par
rapport à Churchill on attend pas ça de
de G on attend tout de même d'un homme
qui est financé hébergé par les Anglais
peut-être un peu plus de d'humilité mais
mais d'emblé il est dans un dans une
posture qui est celle de l'intransigence
et il sait très bien alors on pourrait
rajouter à cela qu'il est pas
spécialement anglophile que culture
n'est pas non je dirais pas anglophobe
mais non mais il est pas anglophile il
est plus il est plus germanophile qu'il
n'est anglophile dans sa culture donc il
connaît mal l'Angleterre il connait mal
ce pays et puis il a il a tous les
souvenirs j'allais dire il disait tout
le temps je vous dis les choses depuis
1000 ans il avait des souvenirs
quasiment de 1000 ans de relation entre
la France et l'Angleterre donc tout ça
c'était c'était ça compte pour un homme
comme De Gaulle cette mémoire elle
compte là où chchill est un homme
effectivement que je dirais plutôt
francophile en tout cas qui aime la
France et cetera c'est ça fait une
différence majeure entre les deux deg
est très méfiant c'est ça il est très
méfiant il est il est pas anclophobe
comme son père l'était lui
euh
Lane il les soupçonne d'un tempas de
crime dont beaucoup sont imaginaires
d'ailleurs il le soupçonnera d'êt
anglophobe il ah oui mais ça c'était une
façon de de voilà s'il faisait pas les
concessions il était donc anglophobe
voilà mais c'est c'est pas vraiment ce
qu'il y a ce que Churchill n'a jamais
compris c'est ce que disait tout le
temps de Gaulle je suis trop faible pour
faire des concessions alors évidemment
pour pour chchill c'est pas
compréhensible hein c'est quand on est
faible qu'on fait les concessions pour
de Gaulle c'est le contraire hein et
euh Churchill est aussi quelqu'un
évidemment de très autoritaire hein
euh
tout ce que je demande c'est qu'on se
plie à ma volonté après un temps de
discussion raisonnable il demande pas
grandchose il demande que ça de Gaul
avec ga ça marche pas du tout c'est les
intérêts de la France doivent être
sauvegardés on va voir un extrait du
film parce qu'il y a un trè homme qui va
se mettre entre entre de Gaul et
Churchill et c'est celui qui préside la
plus grande puissance mondiale de
l'époque c'est
Roosevelt nous parlâes de Roosevelt et
de son attitude à mon égard ne brusqu
rien dit Monsieur Churchill voyez
comment tour à tour je plie et me
relève vous le pouvez observaije parce
que vous êtes assis sur un état solide
une nation rassemblée un empire uni de
grandes armées mais moi où sont mes
moyens pourtant j'ai vous le savez la
charge des intérêts et du destin de la
France c'est trop lourd et je suis trop
pauvre pour que je puisse me
courber monsieur Churchill conclut notre
entretien par une démonstration d'amitié
et d'émotion nous avons encore de rudes
obstacles à surmonter mais un jour nous
serons en France peut-être l'année
prochaine en tout cas nous y serons
ensemble je ne vous lâcherai pas on est
sans doute au moment de crise pass le le
plus fort entre les deux hommes
l'opération torche fin 42 et puis cette
conférence à Casablanca dont nous avons
ramener les images avec ce jeu avec Giro
soutenu par par Roosevelt et church hein
là on est au au plus fort de de ce
qu'ont été les tensions entre les deux
il y aura d'autres encore d'autres
moments de tension et notamment juste
avant la libération au moment du
débarquement dont de Gaulle ne sera pas
et donc ça va être très crispé même
l'arrivée de Churchill à Paris ça va pas
se faire aussi facilement qu'on le croit
donc ça c'est l'image d'Épinal par la
suite avec le recul a bien arrangé tout
ça mais quand on lit les mémoires et les
lettres les correspondances euh c'est à
chaque fois on a l'impression que ça va
rompre entre eux en fait il il n'était
pas fait pour se pour s'aimer tellement
les tempéraments les caractères sont
sont aux antipodes l'un de l'autre mais
après ça s'arrange en tout cas là c'est
vrai que avec le l'opération torche
l'arrivée de Roosevelt qui va en
permanence essayer de convaincre chchill
de prendre ses distances avec ce
Français insupportable ça va créer
quelque chose de très très dur moi
j'admire j'admire finalement la
résistance Churchill vis-à-vis de
Roosevelt Churchill aurait eu ce mot je
je vous a le citer à la conférence de de
Casablanca justement son pays a
abandonné la lutte lui-même n'est qu'un
réfugié et si nous lui retirons notre
appluie c'est un homme fini et bien
regardez-le dit-il en parlant de Gaulle
non mais regardez-le on croirait Staline
avec 200 divisions derrière lui voilà ça
c'était c'était du turchill s'exprimant
sur De Gaulle à cette fameuse conférence
de de Casablanca il y a d'autres moment
très for de tension le débarquement de
Gaulle n'est mis au courant que le 4
juin le débarquement a lieu 2 jours plus
tard notamment très forte tension s'il
fallait en garder un ou deux de ces
moments de très forte tension entre les
hommes ça serait lesquels pour vous ah
pour moi ça serait le
le le Liban en 43 et la Syrie en 45 pour
lesquels
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire les
mémoires de De Gaulle ne sont pas
fiables du tout hein euh il est
contredit sur sa version des
événements par C les archives de C pays
différents et par ses propres archives
c'est-à-dire que alors c'est ce qui est
sympathique chez De Gaulle si vous
voulez c'est que il ne ment
pas pour se mettre en valeur il ment
pour mettre en valeur la France et il se
trouve que en 43 à beroutth et en 4 5 à
Damas le rôle de la France du fait des
personnes qui étaient en charge à
l'époque a été parfaitement lamentable
et donc il ne pouvait pas raconter la
vérité hein et et donc qu'est-ce qu'il
fait et bien il invente un complot
britannique dans les deux cas c'est la
faute des anglais c'est pas la faute de
mon représentant sur place qu' a rappelé
d'ailleurs dans les deux cas parce que
il s'était très mal comporté mais il
fallait pas que ça sache donc les les
mémoires sont à la glire de la France
donc la France ne peut pas s'être
trompée mais dans ses archives sur le
Levant en par particulier on voit très
bien que il savait la vérité il la
savait parfaitement mais il pouvait pas
la dire donc il a inventé il il y a des
passage comme ça il faut dire c'est du
roman feilleton oui les moments de
tension il y en a eu tout de suite en
fait il y en a eu tout de suite parce
qu'il y a eu autant de de personnag on a
toujours cherché quelqu'un qui pourrait
finalement écarter de Gaul et le
remplacer ça a été il y a même un moment
où chchill a sondé Catrou pu final
Catrou a fait acte d'allégence
immédiatement à de George Catrou qui
était un a d'ailleurs plus gradé que de
Gaulle mais qui avait accepté de d'une
certaine manière de de reconnaître que
de Gaulle c'était la France et peu
importe finalement le nombre d'étoiles
qui avaient sur leur KPI et puis il y a
eu la tentative prolongée de de de
mettre Muselier en scène on a oublié
mais c'est ce n'est pas rien je relate
assez longuement d'ailleurs tout ce ce
psychodrame degul avait pris la mesure
des autres il savait à peu près qu'il
n'avait pas grandchose à risquer de
Girot et de Muselier mais il n'empêche
qu'ils avaient eux des soutiens que lui
n'avait pas et il avait notamment vous
parlez de de complot britannique je
pense que de GA pouvait à juste titre
imaginer que tantant il y avait des
complots contre lui alors le le cas du
Levant est un peu est un peu particulier
mais euh et puis il y a eu Giro bien sûr
et puis l'épisode d'arland donc c'est
autant de raisons d'affrontement quasi
permanent et accentué par le par
l'arrivée de rosevelt d'une certaine
manière dans dans dans dans la guerre
dès l'instant que les États-Unis entrent
en guerre c'est le grand large qu'il
emporte sur sur tout le reste et donc il
y a quand même une collusion même une
conivance de Churchill avec avec
Roosevelt très prolongé et il a fallu
tout de même que que de Gaulle et cette
capacité de de de résistance surtout
qu'il est les moyens de rassembler
autour de lui la résistance d'avoir des
atouts extrêmement forts à opposer à
tout cela mais sans arrêt il a été sur
le fil parce que Roosevelt voulait d'une
manière d'une manière permanente la tête
de De Gaulle en finir avec de Gaulle et
Churchill le soutenait tout en étant
dans l'équivoque qui était lié
précisément à cette relation avec
privilégié qu'il avait avec les
États-Unis et de Gaul ne dir digérera
jamais de ne pas avoir été informé en
temps et en heure de ce
débarquement et il n'ya aucune
célébration du débarquement par la suite
alors il est il est tout de même il est
tout de même là il est tout de même à
Londres au moment où ça va mais mais il
est pas au courant de cela il est tenu à
l'écart et surtout le premier
débarquement dont il ignore tout c'est
le débarquement d'Afrique du Nord et et
qui est d'ailleurs assez baroque puisque
finalement les vichistes vont tirer sur
les sur les alliés et cetera et là ça
nous ramène à novembre 42 le
parol mais vous avez admiré la la
résistance de Churchill par rapport à à
à Roosevelt en fait elle était
extrêmement faible il a été obligé de
résister pourquoi parce que son cabinet
et notamment
idon et Atle ont refusé la rupture avec
de Gaulle hein et et donc il a été
obligé de dire à et et le roi aussi et
sa femme
aussi et donc il a été obligé de dire à
à Roosevelt ben je suis obligé le
Parlement est maintenant pour de
Gaulle l'opinion publ et pour de Gaulle
je peux pas je peux pas rompre avec lui
en fait c'est ça hein et et donc il
était ch de Gaul le comprenait très bien
il l'a dit hein Churchill me considère
comme un meuble bien encombrant auquel
il se heurte de temps en temps mais qui
fait maintenant partie du décor et qu'on
ne peut plus déplacer il en jouit il le
savait à partir de 43 fin 43 il savaiit
très bien que les Anglais ne pouvaient
pas céder à à Roosevelt qui lui était
effectivement atteint d'une grave
maladie c'est une golophobie aigue hein
et que bah ma fois il fallait supporter
il nous reste TR minutes vous avez
commencé votre film avec cette journée
du du 30 janvier 65 sont les funérailles
de national de Churchill bien entendu de
goliiva en spectacle spectacle
extraordinaire avec les grues qui se
lèvent sur la Tamise enfin c'est inoui
inoui ouais il aurait eu des mots très
forts vis-à-vis de concernant Churchill
de De Gaulle à ce moment-là oui mais
c'est normal c'est la c'est la fin c'est
la réconciliation il y a plus de guerre
il y a plus de crise mais les 4 années
quand même qui est qui sont au centre de
du documentaire c'est quand même une
tension permanente vous allez me dire
c'est la guerre oui d'accord mais tout
de même ça n'arrête pas une seconde
enfin du côté de du côté de Gaulle c'est
il est tout tout le temps tout le temps
dans la guerre interne intérieure jerais
juste évoquer une chose c'est qu'il y a
dans le documentaire une archive que je
trouve extraordinaire c'est celle de la
conférence d'enfa Casablanca où on les
voit
répéter les mains vous allez serer une
deuxième fois la main de Giro c'est
inoui et de GA qui disaiit ça c'est
çaoui une petite chose et d'ailleurs
Roosevelt a l'air de prendre un malin
plaisir à à refire la prise après guerre
la relation entre les deux hommes
jusqu'à la mort de jeis juste raconter
une ENF une anecdote qui qui qui est que
j'ai découvert dans les dans les
mémoires de De Gaulle de Gaulle raconte
ça ça dit ça dit beaucoup de choses de
la relation entre les deux hommes et
aussi du du goût du mythe pas pas du
mensonge mais deun façon de mythifier
l'histoire euh de GO raconte sa dernière
rencontre avec avec Churchill et
Churchill al première version de goécrit
dit Churchill me dit amitié puis de GA
reprend et il remplace le mot amitié il
fait dire à Churchill vive la France
c'est extraordinaire parce que c'est
c'est tout à fait et évidemment c'est le
dernier au fond le dernier affrontement
il est littéraire en quelque sorte oui
alors petite chose dans dans le film
vous
dites
Churchill maîtrisait bien le
français c'est très indulgent hein parce
que Churchill massacrait couramment le
français mais son français c'était de
l'anglais décalqué hein poresque d'aurs
mot à mot donc et ch s'en rendait bien
compte puisqu'il a dit ceci à à à de
Gaulle en janvier 44 à à Casablanca
euh maintenant que le général parle si
bien l'anglais il comprend parfaitement
mon français oui effectivement il
fallait parler l'anglais pour comprendre
le français de chch et ce ce ce fameux
jour du 30 janvier 65 funérail de
Churchill de Gaul en verra une lettre à
la reine ellisabeth i avec ses mots dans
ce grand drame il fut le plus grand un
grand merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce dbad dooc
aujourd'hui sur la base de votre film
c'est il est exclusif pour notre chaîne
Pierre Assouline les réactions sont
nombreuses je l'imagine elles seront à
trouver sur hashtag desbadog vous
pourrez réagir hein d'ailleurs à ce que
sont les les réactions de nos
téléspectateurs merci à Selma sali Sarah
udline qui m'ont aidé à préparer cette
émission et je vous retrouve tout
simplement pour un prochain débat dooc
ça sera bien sûr avec son documentaire
et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt